[Music]
christina ellis ramsey personality
newest ramsey personality is joining me
for a segment here i want to make sure
you guys all get to know her and you'll
be hearing a lot more from her in the
coming weeks and coming years
and uh we look forward to that welcome
thank you thanks for having me so
christina has quite a storied background
before she joined our team she had a
best-selling book called confessions of
a scholarship winner and how to books
and how to graduate debt free
she started a website called
collegeninja.com that we are melding
into the ramsey stuff as well and she is
a college ninja without a doubt she uh
secured over 500 000 dollars in
scholarships
went to vanderbilt and got her degree
and got a master's degree as well and
all of it's supported by scholarships so
she's walking living proof that you can
go to school debt-free and that it's
possible right yes absolutely yes if you
are willing to fight for it and put
together a strategy there is no reason
that you need debt for college you can
do it
so
lest someone think that this is a uh
privileged situation that sets you up
for this none of these scholarships were
athletic
none of them were academic
your dad passed away of cancer when you
were seven
and so you're being raised by a single
mom and she sat down with you and had a
conversation yes the first day of my
freshman year of high school my mom sat
me down she said christina i love you
and i believe in you but there's just no
way that i can support you financially
once you graduate from high school so
you got to figure out your own way to
pay for college and at first i was
shocked i thought why are you telling me
this i am a freshman in high school what
can i do about it but at the same time i
knew that she was just trying to help
and cast a vision for me
yeah and she's she's your mom i love
your mom
i mean she's just old school she's
venezuelan is that what it was yes yes
from venezuela came here married an
american and your dad and he passed away
and so she's like scratching and clawing
immigrant mentality get her done baby
you know kind of woman and this is this
woman's a force of nature
she's a anything but a victim and wasn't
going to allow you to be oh yeah she's
such a fighter and the thing is that she
immigrated from venezuela in her 20s she
actually got a scholarship to come here
to the united states and she grew up in
a pretty rough background kind of the
slums of venezuela so she in her
perspective was like i got you this far
so now what are you gonna do like here's
the baton you better run hard and fast
to get to the next level yeah you
already got a whole bunch more than i
got so no whining and here's what we're
gonna do but she didn't just dump it on
you as a ninth grader
and leave you uh
penniless or or hopeless she actually
was your cheerleader and really gave you
a system she was an incredible
cheerleader and i actually love that she
told me in ninth grade i think that all
parents need to have those conversations
as early as possible because she let me
know the reality of what i was going to
face and she gave me time to come up
with a strategy you know i read every
book every resource i
interviewed alumni from my high school
to figure out you know what does it take
to win scholarships and how can i stand
out in the process you know she
encouraged me to put together a plan and
strategy and then i implemented it all
throughout high school i just
continually what did you do
i got involved in extracurricular
activities i worked on building up my
grades i took the right classes i took
up leadership roles i volunteered you
know i wasn't a star athlete i didn't
have perfect grades so i had to figure
out you know how can i stand out in the
process and something that i did is i
volunteered a ton i did over a thousand
hours of community service when i was in
high school and i continued to create
opportunities and just look for ways
that were unique to stand out
also doing things that i love i
encourage people you know when you're
trying to get involved in high school
and stand out in the process don't just
do things because they stand out in the
scholarship application process do
things that you love when you're doing
things that you love you're going to
want to pour into them and then
naturally stand out
and then you filled out scholarship
applications and essays like
daily yes my mom and i kind of lived in
the library and that's another cool
thing about my mom is like she didn't
just tell me what to do you know she
would sit with me at night and we would
talk about applications we would do the
research together on the computer and we
would just she would be my cheerleader
when i was applying you know i would get
bored sometimes and be like oh do i have
to do these applications come on and she
would you know help me take a break and
be like you know let's go grab some
coffee let's just like make this a fun
process and let's do this you know she
helped me stay pumped up
yeah and so how many scholarships do you
think you applied for i applied for
around 50 scholarships which actually
now that i do this for a living and i
talk to people about scholarships i
encourage people to apply for a lot more
you know i was very fortunate that i won
some very big scholarships but i love to
see students applying for 100 or 200
scholarships because the more you put
yourself out there the greater chance
you have of winning yeah and 100 at 250
gets a lot of money yes it adds up it
adds up incredibly fast yeah and you can
go through school
debt free now we've got the book here
debt free degree by anthony o'neill that
we teach people how to go to school
debt-free
college choice is a big part of it
but if you get 500 000 worth you don't
even have to worry about college choice
right yeah i was very fortunate i was
able to go to vanderbilt university for
my undergrad in belmont for grad school
completely debt-free and they are not
cheap schools both of them are expensive
yes both of them are really expensive
yeah so but if you if you don't get 500
000 worth you have you need to choose a
school that is within the budget of the
money you can get your hands on whether
it's scholarship money or working or
wherever you're going to get the money
you choose a school that's within that
budget and that is the number one thing
that drives people into college debt yes
i always want people to explore their
options that's the thing is that there
are so many choices out there i feel
like a lot of students get stuck on this
idea of a specific school that cost 50
or 70 thousand dollars and you don't
have to go that direction there are so
many different options for a debt-free
degree you know there are tons of free
community colleges nowadays there are a
lot of employers that are offering
incredible tuition benefits a lot of
employers are now offering free college
if you work for them plus you can still
earn money while you're employed so it's
it's really cool to see all of these
options growing and expanding the first
time i ever saw that ups was doing it in
louisville in their home office and you
could load trucks and they pay for you
to go to school at the university of
louisville
and um you know that's a was an
incredible benefit now a ton of people
are doing that with the current
upside-down world we've got on labor and
labor shortage and it's 15 an hour to
work at target and they'll pay for your
college and so you know probably 10 or
15 other major employers are offering
that benefit
and so if you want to go to school
debt-free you need to be willing to work
you need to be willing to set aside time
and apply for scholarships you need to
be very careful about your college
choice oh and did i mention you need to
work
yes
and that's what's so cool is that you
can literally work and make an income
while getting a free degree so it's like
you avoid student loans completely and
you're making money which it's like
that's kind of the best of both worlds
you can follow christina i am christina
ellis on twitter and on instagram you'll
learn more about scholarships and more
about ramsey money principles and as
she's joined the money section of the
ramsey personality team and certainly
with a specialization in this but you'll
hear her talking about all the other
things as she joins this show in the
coming weeks and months and joins our
lineup and our our events and things
you'll see are everywhere welcome to the
team christina thank you thanks for
having me i'm thrilled to be here gonna
be gonna be a great ride this lady's a
smart lady
she's uh way smarter than me
you put her and john dolone in the same
room my iq goes up just walking in there